uh he's got a podcast cinephile on the
meadowlark media network he's on mlb's
on dazon
had a cup of coffee with a wwe and sat
with me
during the sundance screening of sorry
to bother you
a film that we hope to never see again
it's my dear friend adnan vark how are
you adnan
ben great to be with you as always i
thought you're gonna say speaking of
short form content here's my short
friend admin
yes thank you for running through the
laurels that we've done together
only you can appreciate this and then
we'll get to whatever you need to talk
about because this is very
self-indulgent but i finally read the
mark harris book
pictures in a revolution you know this
is a critical book among
city acids and the files he talks about
bonnie and clyde guess who's coming
together in the heat of the night et
cetera
came out like 13 years ago right i
finally read the book i reach out to our
producer chris cody who you know and
love and say hey
i know mark harris is a new book about
mike nichols out but i finally want to
read i've read if i read the book
i want to talk to mark about it random
house all over it sends me the copy of
this new book about mike nichols 600
page book for those who don't know
one best director the graduate may and
nichols i mean obviously legendary
director etc
so i'm here at work right now i'm ready
to come on mlb network
once the rangers and tigers are over but
i'm locked into this mike nichols
biography how many other people are
doing this other than you and me
uh honestly adnan you are one of one i
am always amazed at your passion for
vaisika hema as well as
amanda seifried so you just really have
the whole spectrum covered
i love a good eagle's punt returner he
was great back in the day love bye
i do love buy i do want to uh talk about
my dodgers out here in la being that one
of your many jobs is working for m the
mlb network dodger fans starting to boo
kenley janssen at the stadium what's
happening
so it's crazy i remember a month ago or
so brian kenny another former expander
who does a great job here at mlb
was saying look at the numbers kelly
chances have a great season like he is
like
i hadn't really paid enough attention to
it i was like oh yeah actually had
really put together i remember
you and i were texting a year ago like
dude he's done like if it's
it's frustrating it's upsetting i know
how great he's been but you can't rely
on this guy i couldn't imagine coming
back but ultimately
he was able to bounce back after last
season had a great first half but now
lately
you've seen the concerns you see why i
still think it isn't
a strength for the dodgers you can see
what you want with the dodgers right now
but the fact that ultimately you don't
believe in this guy
now listen it was his first blown save
at home against the giants since 2013.
and dave roberts for the record said he
was disappointed to hear dodgers fans
blooming james
but i get it ben when you're a dodger
die hard you go we can't go through this
again
and these games are so critical like say
this for the giants everyone keeps
saying well they're not as good as the
dodgers we'll wait and see what's second
half in the first half and one of the
easiest schedules in baseball the last
time i checked for almost the trading
deadline and they're still in first
place
so until la catches them san francisco
is really the team to be
right now the national league west and
the padres are five and a half games
back and they stole the headlines
and i love tatties he's so electrifying
but the giants need to get some respect
posey's been remarkable brandon crawford
they're starting pitching is no joke
diesel funny kevin gossman could win the
scion if it wasn't for degrom so
unfortunate to hear the blue birds but i
think it's basically an indictment of
the fact that dodgers fans know ben
san francisco is legit and these games
are critical fun fact about the san
francisco giants they recently hired a
former nfl linebacker named brian peters
as a special breath consultant brian now
works with professional athletes
and helps them master their breath on
the mound on the field on the pitch
and have breath control and the giants
have hired brian
and his services i know this because i
met him at the car rental place over a
three-hour wait
and uh we became fast friends as i was
struggling with my breathing
so fun fact about the san francisco
giants uh adnan
there was so much talk about the star
power of shohei ohtani during the
mlb all-star festivities since then he's
gone to throw six innings and he's had
another home run
but i i look at these nba finals and i'm
like wow bobby portis is a household
name across america that's because he's
playing
when it matters most if the angels can't
keep getting in the postseason
or being in games that matter come
october how do you think that impacts
the star power of shohei ohtani as long
as
he's in anaheim i don't think it impacts
at all but i'll be honest it'll be great
to see him thrive in october i'd love to
see him with a world series
but nothing is slowing down the emotion
and the cavalcade of
of roaring right now for otani in the
last couple days he saw an exclusive
multi-year memorabilia deal
with fanatics he's signing baseballs 450
bucks
jersey 700 bucks photos 390 bucks right
now for finance to sell the mlb online
show
this is after he accounted for 28 of all
all-star game merchandise sales that's
one dude
among 40 who's accounting for almost 30
percent
of all the sales and since the start of
july he is the top selling athlete
on fanatics across all sports let me
repeat
that is the almighty nfl that is the nba
that is hockey there's mls
he's the number one selling guy now
since the start of july he's making
six million dollars in endorsements
annually that's the most effective any
active player in baseball so
i'm with you that the narrative would be
a lot nicer if photonic goes into
october
and dominates but the angels pitching is
horrid and that's not going to happen
this year
but there is no denying this guy's
charisma and his one-of-a-kind ability
when it comes to pitching and
specifically hitting
the fact he's leaving the league in home
runs i'd love to see him in the playoffs
for right now it doesn't matter
nothing can dull the star power of
ohtani adnan burke joins the show you
know him from mlb network and dazn as
well as the host of the cinephile
podcast
part of the meadowlark media empire
yesterday the other cinna
host on meadowlark amino hassan came on
this show
and said that his sinner podcast was the
best in a podcast
on the platform as the host of cinephile
what do you have to say about the host
of cinephobe
and his harsh comments uh listen i love
amino hash he's a wonderful guy
obviously he had a few uh moments
together east pin when i was filming
with priscilla
i know what he's doing he's trying to
bait me into some sort of tug of war but
listen i respect the opposition i don't
know what the numbers are i can't
actually look at the data but
i think we both have loyal audiences
clearly he looks at bad movies
i look at great movies and i was a
previous guest by the way on
cinephone so this is kind of like when
leno used to be a guest on letterman all
the time and then eventually they had
this big rivalry in the big separation
so listen
i've been a guest of the show when he
really set me up ben he goes hey which
of the following movies do you love
and i of course still the premise of the
show which is that whatever i like he's
going to hate
but i believe the options were like you
know the departed cape fear
shape of water i knew shape of water
would be a tougher argument so
with the departed and then i went on a
show and he kept telling me how the
departed stinks and i'm like listen
uh are we all though it's not chris says
he's best it's still a really good movie
and as i pointed out
when you look at that year you cannot
tell me babel is a movie that you're
looking to watch more than the departed
all right
it's still elite company it's still
elite talent
and um even if i didn't win that war
with the media on this podcast
i think cinephile is more than holding
its own adnan this is why i love having
you on the show because we were actually
talking babble in studio
earlier in the week here on the rich
eisen show so where else are you gonna
get two babble references than when
adnan comes on the show
and something about cinephile that uh
cinephobe doesn't have cinephile's been
to the academy awards
yeah absolutely but to say our eighth in
the hole is my man ben lyons who clearly
took cinephile which was this fledgling
entity and then you gave us
actual street cred by getting me to the
oscars not once but twice
we won an emmy together although i don't
even know what the category is
it was too long it was like best
interactive use of social media within
an entertainment venue
and then we got and then we got
nominated again the next year so you're
right ben lines is my secret weapon and
i love the fact
you've been by the way i mean it's three
different iterations here of cinephile
espn
cadence13 and that was metallurgy you've
been a part of every one of us so you
are
part of the hatchery well i appreciate
that adnan and i know like you growing
up a young boy who loved film you always
dreamed of winning
best interactive live stream at an event
across multiple platforms also being
hosted by a disney star
so i think that's something we all got
to live out our dreams on
um but what do you remember about those
oscar nights i know you got to interact
with kobe bryant the year that he won an
academy award you got to call
the the missing envelope the mistaken
envelope
uh between la la land and moonlight one
of the great calls in the history of
broadcasting what do you remember from
those oscar nights
that was mike do you believe in miracles
moment as you know i was in la
a couple weeks ago for the zone calling
it two fights unfortunately you weren't
in la at the time i would have loved to
see you but
in honor of you because whenever i'm in
l.a i think of you and hanging with you
so
i actually did the pilgrimage i went to
the kodak theater i just hopped in an
uber
went there just check it out like i
relived that memory as silly as that
they seem
walking i mean there's no red carpet
there now but in that area and looking
up those
that glorious staircase as you go up
into the kodak theater then of course
you were backstage so
dude it was it was remarkable it looks a
little different on a thursday in july
across the street from a hooters on
hollywood boulevard doesn't it
i was about to say so black widow you're
right it was a thursday night and black
widow was opening so i
maybe i forget this but i didn't realize
jimmy kimmel is next door like it's
across the street from
the kodak theater so all these fans are
actually lining up in the theater to go
see black widow i'm thinking all right i
mean it was
it was okay i love seeing ray winston
pick up a check speaking of the departed
by man frenchy
but it is a little bit different when
you just see you know passerby wandering
around and
strong smell of weed in the air like
okay this isn't exactly the love of
cinephiles that i was thinking would be
but
we go back to those memories together
i'll never forget we had one of the most
immortal moments ever together it wasn't
just my call you were there with me
when we saw that moonlight actually won
best picture
and it wasn't la la land our guy camera
denny danny was his name the stage
manager he was the one pointing to the
camera to our right
and as you were talking and filming
thomas j carson i looked over and i just
saw
kleiner and and i didn't realize what
the hell was happening but i realized
that clearly la la land was not best
picture and then in real time
we kind of made that call together and
you had the great athletes still a great
night for the academy but
all i really cared about ben was this i
befriended barry jenkins because i knew
he was a big college football fan
so we had dm each other and in november
of that year before moonlight was
released but it was creating some buzz
we had him on cinephile and he was
awesome and then when i saw him there
on the red carpet just you know
basically said hey i'm pulling for him
blah blah blah and he was great it
couldn't have been more gracious
so all i cared about was not only that
barry one and moonlight was vindicated
but i hoped he would hear my call
because of course selfishly that's all i
cared about
and when we had one cinephile let's say
six months later i think it was actually
it was a year later it was about if
beale street could talk
i'd always say it was like a barry did
you hear my call like i know you were
there
and you saw what happened with kimmel
but did you see what i did because
honestly
i went back to florida state to receive
something and they played
your call i'm like all right that's all
i care about oh my god do you believe in
miracles
you know i was a part of film history
adnan burke joins the show the host of
the cinephile podcast a dear friend and
a correspondent of course and host for
mlb network and design
and adnan something i really enjoy about
that night in particular we got a chance
to go to a fun little oscar after party
i'm just
looking for the free food because we've
been on our feet all day long
this is an opportunity for you to go up
to literally everyone in hollywood and
just say something and i just always
appreciate
your approach like if you see michael
keaton on oscar night what do you do
what do you go up and say to him so i'm
waiting in line for some french fries
and it's michael keaton and his lady and
me and my wife amen and i wasn't sure
what to say
and as i'm thinking of some clever witty
thing i could say to michael keaton
he turns and makes eye contact because
hey i didn't how you doing
now i almost fainted that michael keaton
actually knows who i
am should we start blubbering away and
and clearly my wife made a mistake
because she said something i love batman
which he was okay with but i think he
might have a slight eye roll like okay
another batman or when's the next
beetlejuice coming out something like
that
but i quickly thought of game six which
is a great little baseball indie movie
in which michael keaton plays a
playwright much like your dad diehard
red sox fan
and he has a play opening up on broadway
and all he cares about is game 686
of course that immortal world series
buckner against the match so i mentioned
game six too many actually he did
smiling as well man thanks so much he's
doing
the movie for like nothing because i
don't even know how little we made but
i'm so glad you saw it i said of course
as a baseball lover indie mood lover i
thought it was wonderful
and let me talk about the pirates you
know he's always a big pittsburgh gun i
said man i wish the parts are better
clementine bridge is so nice et cetera
and
he kind of made a joke something about i
was in a good mood before i talked to
now you brought the fact that pirates
stinking will for a long time
and after that i realized it was my time
to make a quick getaway but i love the
fact that when i would see start and get
excited like john fabry like i know john
like i can introduce you i dude
that's a good guy i just want to tell
him i love swingers i'm not that's it i
just go up a little swinger slide
and move on to the next person it was
such a great nightmare i can't thank you
enough
adenine burke joining the show in
addition to his work with the mlb
covering film with me at the academy
awards adnan has a little bit of juice
still in the world of wwe
we're in the presence of some wwe
legends in here and tj jefferson and
chris brockman you guys have anything
pressing about the wwe that you need to
ask adnan take it away tj
and then i just i mean if you're up for
talking about it i mean you had it you
had a quick cup of coffee there
and i was just wondering like how was
your experience
listen honestly the people there were
awesome i mean i'll never say
a bad word about corey graves and about
byron saxton you know we all know what
it's like when you're on a team
and you're the weakest link and that's
never a good feeling and those guys and
i knew i was obviously the weakest link
but
they never made me feel that way they
were so kind and supportive and
recognizing the fact that you know i
never called wrestling on any level
i hadn't followed the sport a long time
and i was trying to learn on the fly as
corey said to me because
you are learning something on live
television in this age of social media
and trolls like
i don't have you the position you're in
but you have all the tools here for
success so
we all know it's all about teammates
that are always being dead to cory and
byron how great they were in terms of
hey
i'll call more the terminology you call
the finishers we can we can help you
finesse this and
it was very very generous of them people
often ask about the wrestlers themselves
all great you know when
when i was dismissed and and things
didn't work out drew mcintyre reached
out right away jinder mahal of course i
would love south asian and canadian
um big he was awesome he's a huge
college football guy he messaged me as a
dude
i hope you're not you know you know i
don't have any uh bad feelings about
this experience it's a really hard job
to do play by play blow blind blow for
monday night raw
they three in the pool and um you know
hopefully we'll see at some point the
weird thing and you guys know this is
wwe
there's a lot of comebacks man there's a
lot more comebacks and that sports but i
think even in boxing so
who knows maybe i could resurface one
day but i i really did enjoy my
experience
i'm grateful the people i worked with i
wish i'd done a better job you know
that's on me i wish i'd been better at
it but um
it was a grind i mean i've got four boys
ages 13 10
four and two as ben listed all my jobs
it's pretty hard when i'm leaving every
sunday flying their monday night raw
tuesday fly back first thing
and i'm worried about my kid dentist
appointments and oh by the way i've got
a two-hour show so
i don't nobody cares about my problems
and issues but it was a lot of work to
do
but i'm grateful to happen and i got to
meet vince mcmahon a couple of times and
obviously had live feedback from him so
it was a really cool experience for sure
as ben said to me afterwards when he
texted me it's a great story one day to
tell the grandkids well i just love
watching you on doing the
the monday night raw thing wwe just
sneaking in or promising young woman
reference
well i was so grateful you saw that
because you know i've listened the
cavalcade of negativity was kind of
tough to overcome whenever i would check
social media so thank god
i would get a text from my friend ben
lyons because this is after the oscars
and i'm like okay how many movie
references can i get in and of course
most the audience is not going to get
them but thank god my boy ben
recognizing a mandy rose bump shot god's
greatest creation i said there she is
promising a woman up next and as they
text had been afterwards you know how
many people actually got the reference
this is a movie
about a woman who's like been assaulted
he's trying to get revenge on men
and i'm just getting it in here monday
night rob fairly certain most the ice
didn't get it thank god bent it
and then we sadly have to say goodbye
didn't have time to talk about silence
your favorite religious persecution
movie that you drove three hours to new
york city to see on christmas day but
something to say for next time on the
show thanks so much buddy how about this
ben i included the zone la a couple
weeks ago and of the movies available on
the flight
silence was one of them i couldn't
believe it i did watch quick changes i
love one of my dad's favorite comedies
the great billbury only movie he
directed i rewatched him on malcolm x
again i watched king of kong which i
know you know it's a documentary from
07. i finally saw it king of kong
a fist full of quarters but silence was
available so my next flight i'll dial it
up thanks boys
and then burns
nice of him to join us after taking a
break from being the micro machines guy
yeah
thanks mr testavirty strong reference
anybody here
able to pull that one i love that dude
he's like listening to a podcast on
speed and a half
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here